hi my name is Barry Scheck so from in
Thai capital I work in Intel's venture
organization who amassed into technology
startups around the world and one of the
fun part of my job is investing in young
entrepreneurs who are willing to take
huge risks with their life and willing
to change the world and it also gives me
someone pain to see the increasing
unemployment among young population
mainly students but on the other end I
see that as a huge opportunity for
entrepreneurship with the right
mentorship and with the right ecosystem
around capitals capital markets or the
legal system and the regulations i think
is young students and young
professionals have a great opportunity
especially at the time of the big
technology innovation that we are living
through and and i think a lot of those
young minds should think more about how
they can change the world rather than
how they can change the arrangement to
start in another large organization and
get lost in the big ecosystem of the
politics and bureaucracy in the large
corporation so I strongly advise those
young new grads or young professionals
to think about it how what can they do
to change the world and create their own
opportunities rather than being stuck on
the current macroeconomic problems and
an eventual high unemployment but think
more about how what they can do to
change the world and start their own
companies thank you